dope is a smaller film you may not have
heard of but it isn't a wide release
this weekend a small wide release it is
about three high school kids who aren't
really the most popular kids in school
they've chosen to be different in almost
every single way they're obsessed with
90s hip-hop they like to dress like the
right out of an episode of Fresh Prince
of bel-air they have their own band in
which they write their own original
music and our lead character is a
humongous geek who still plays Super
Nintendo and when he accidentally gets
involved with the wrong group of people
he has to do everything he can to stay
who he is and maintain his dignity dope
is an extremely original movie I haven't
seen a movie like this in a long time
it's filled with excellent performances
especially the lead shameik Moore and
dude I apologize if I said her name
wrong because you are a class act talent
my friend this guy is so good in this
film he was so good at being this
character this guy who gets picked on in
school all the time but he never really
looked like he was trying to get
sympathy from the audience he never
really tried to be tear jerky you know
he was always very real and that's a
really hard thing to do when you're
playing a character who's in a rough
area of town who gets beaten up who
doesn't have a lot of money who just
doesn't fit in and he's never asking the
audience like me just because of these
things he is so good in this movie and
I'll honesty everyone is really good in
this film zoe kravitz is also and it's
probably the best I've ever seen her but
what I loved about this movie was the
directors original point of view the
editing the shot structure the
cinematography the music especially the
soundtrack oh my gosh what a great
soundtrack this movie was so energetic
it had such a charisma to it now the
rough area these kids are growing up in
is called Inglewood California now I've
been there the first time I went to LA I
actually stayed in Inglewood with my
buddy John flicking jerk the flick pic
we stayed in the hotel in Inglewood the
first room we got there actually had
legit toenails in the bedsheets
I'm not kidding we asked for a different
room and that one is a little bit better
but let me just say the depiction of
this area it's accurate because I
remember when I stayed there all I heard
was yelling shouting and sirens it was
not fun that's another
the director did a really good job with
he made this location feel like a
character like a living breathing thing
and the movie has a lot of messages or
morals that it's trying to get across to
the audience some of it works really
well others not so much one of the ones
that doesn't is there's this entire side
scene where someone's ranting about
Obama and some of his decisions it just
didn't really work in the movie there
were times like that in this movie where
it was very preachy the overall message
of the movie though is that it doesn't
matter what neighborhood you are from
what kind of income you or your family
has or what skin color you have you can
follow your dreams you can be successful
there is one kind of really questionable
message in the movie though and I can't
really say it because it's a spoiler
someone gets the respect of someone who
was bullying this individual a lot by
doing something really bad and the film
is kind of like this is what you had to
do to get people to respect you and I
was like uh-uh that's gross besides that
I really enjoyed dope I thought it was
an extremely well acted charismatic film
with great editing a great soundtrack
and a really original point of view I'm
gonna give dope a B+ guys thank you so
much as always for watching I strongly
appreciate it and if you did see this
movie I'm curious to know what you
thought of it below and as always thank
you once again and if you like this you
can click right here and get stubborn
eyes